welcome back we are now on section four
of our third test n two are on page 530
and let's start with problem number one
problem number one if s plus t is equal
to 3 s plus t is equal to 3 what is the
value of s plus t minus 6 well we know
that s plus t is equal to 3 so they're
just asking us what is 3-6 well 3 minus
6 is minus 3 and that is choice a number
two okay they have a box on the cube
okay so let's see let me see if I can
draw this box so it looks like and the
back sides like this and then draw a
little dotted okay and then the sides
are a we do that in a different color a
b c d e P and Q and they say on the cube
and the figure above each of the
following point is the same distance
from P as it is from Q except and these
are all the choices a b c d and e so we
want to look for a point that isn't the
same distance as from p as it is from Q
so a a is one edge from p and one edge
from Q so it's not a B is B is let's see
it's two edges from p no matter how you
go and it is also two edges from q no
matter how you go so it's not be it's
the same si si is one edge from Q right
but to get to pee you gotta go at least
three edges one two three to go to see
so it's going to be CC is much closer to
Q then is to pee so it is not the same
distance so our choice is CC you see
alright problem number three and I'll
switch to a less tacky collar problem
number three problem number boy there's
all sorts of stuff to to draw let's see
maybe I won't draw it so I can get by
without dragging the bar graph above
shows where fraud is committed on the
internet which of the following circle
graphs most act will accurately displays
the same graph well I'll try it so you
know they say websites websites and you
know websites is like this huge number
websites that's seventy eight percent
let me say that that is you know I'll
say that's that's this purple color
actually I should do this the rectangle
to the websites is that purple color and
then let's say that you know email
emails I'll do it this collar it's at
eighteen percent and then they tell us
that newsgroups newsgroups it's two
percent so it's a really small
percentage two percent and then finally
they tell us that other is also two
percent others also ten percent and you
want to say see a pie graph that's the
same thing so if this is the pie graph
so seventy-eight percent is going to be
this purple it's going to be websites so
that's a little bit more than
three-fourths right seventy-eight
percent is three percent more than 34 so
three fourths would look like this would
a little bit more than three-fourths
it's going to look something like this
oh whoops oh I'm still using the line
tool but it would look something like a
little bit more than three-fourths is
going to look something like this
and then I can actually even fill it
that's going to be a little bit more
than 34 it's and then the blue stuff
eighteen percent well that's going to be
that's going to look something like
eighteen percent that's a little less
than twenty-five percent so it's going
to be like that so we could fill that
too all right and then the other pieces
are going to be you know these thin
slivers the other pieces are going to be
these thin slivers like this so two
percent of do percent so it's going to
be like two percent and two percent all
right this is really just translating
that into this and it actually going to
be even thinner than the way I drew it
and out of all the choices the one that
has this purple region websites and you
know the dark region on the on the graph
the one that has that where it's more
than three-fourths the only one that has
that more than three-fourths our choice
is C and D right that's the only one
where it has you know more than 75
percent is shaded the websites color so
it's either going to be C or D and then
when you look at the difference in c and
b c choice e has nothing for other in
their right choice e is it just has
newsgroups not no other so it has to be
d because d and because news groups and
others are actually the same size so
there they should be the same proportion
so the choice is d next problem problem
number for the numerator of a certain
fraction is 5 for less than the
denominator so the numerator so let's
say the denominator is X the numerator
is five less than the denominator so the
numerator is X minus 5 right numerator
is five less than the denominator and
they say the fraction is equal to three
fourths what is the denominator of this
fraction so we just solve for x so let's
cross multiply x times 3 so 3 X is equal
to 4 times X minus 5 4 times X minus 5
so 3
x is equal to 4x minus 20 you can
subtract so you get 20 is equal to
subtract 3x from both sides is equal to
x and that's the denominator so that is
choice D now the next problem has a
bunch of drawing for me to do but let's
see if I can finish it in time so we
have the two axes let me draw the 2x
easy this is a big problem so I'll draw
it big I got two proxies and then they
give us you know it goes from k to 6k so
you know k2 k3 k4 k-5 k 6k 6 k 5k for
k3k you get the point then it goes from
1 to 60 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then the
triangle looks like it goes from see if
I were to draw a line goes from 2k 26 k
and then from two to six so goes draw
they actually draw the line like this to
two Gators this is a triangle I don't
have time to do it in this video but
everything should work out see so the
triangle goes from 2k 26 k and it's a
point 2000 sorry goes from 2 k-25 k good
thing I caught that it's from 2k 25 gay
and it's a point to
it's its base and then it goes up to 6
where it kind of is in the middle so it
goes up to here so this is what the
triangle looks like i have redrawn the
problem and this is b a c and they say
in the figure above the scale on the
x-axis is different from the scale on
the y-axis if the area of triangle ABC
is 18 what is the value of K so the area
is 18 so area is equal to one-half base
times height for triangle we know that
the area is 18 so 18 is equal to
one-half what's the base well we went
from two k-25 k right so we went 3 K we
went 123 we went 3 K so the base is 3 k
and what's the height well from two to
six so the height is for right now we
just solve for K so 18 is equal to let's
see one half times 4 is 2 times 3 k is
equal to 6 k k is equal to 3 and that is
choice E and we are done you just have
to know area is equal to one-half base
times height and they're just put in the
base which is 3k and the height and
solve for k i'll see you in the next
video